i feel like a lot of self-development or  getting past procrastination or  productivity whatever is just  mind-hacking it's sort of just tricking  yourselves with little things tricking  your mind i think i read about michael  jordan he would find a way to motivate  himself for every single game that he  played there's probably a kid up there  who's never seen me play he's come for  the first time see michael jordan play  let me show him what it's like it's like  in a relationship you have to actively  work on the relationship yeah i think we  always just assume that yeah it should  work if you're in love you have to  actually actively do it yeah and the  same thing with just getting our brains  to work how we want them to work we have  to fool our brains it's a weird concept  because it's like it's in our brains  ourselves but it's not it's  so we have to do what we can and  whatever works works